family and friends gathered in front of
Rio de Janeiro's iconic Copacabana beach
Israel British journalist Dom Phillips
loved to paddle surf he was shot dead by
poachers a year ago while traveling with
indigenous expert Bruno Pereira in the
Brazilian Amazon
on the first anniversary of their death
Dom's Widow made a plea for the work of
both men to continue
their cause is much bigger than their
death people must be conscious not only
in Brazil but also abroad of what is
going on the Amazon is still in danger
as are the people who are trying to
protect it memorials were also had in
other cities in Brazil from the capital
Brasilia to the Amazon in the Javari
Valley indigenous leaders and experts
placed two crosses in the river where
Dam and Bruno were killed the tributes
coincided with celebrations of
environment day and the announcement by
the government of an ambitious plan to
stop deforestation president
Silva said he would revert his
predecessor's policy who turned a blind
eye to Illegal mining logging and
farming in indigenous territories
Bruno and Dom you deserve to be here
today you have the Brazilian government
as an ally instead of an enemy as was
the case during the past four years the
best way to honor you is making sure
your fight to protect the Amazon has not
been in vain the tributes come at a
crucial moment in Brazilian politics
left as president Louisiana
has promised to defend the indigenous
population and to protect the Amazon
rainforest but he's facing a
conservative dominated Congress backed
by the powerful Farm Lobby who's pushing
for legislation to open protected lands
to commercial exploitation
Lula da Silva's intentions may be good
but back in the Javari Valley nothing
much has changed the territory the size
of Austra is home to the largest number
of uncontacted tribes and they are still
at risk many indigenous leaders like
Beto marubo still receive death threats
the government agencies in charge of
protecting us and the Amazon are still
underfunded and in shambles they don't
have the means to face armed Invaders
financed by growing criminal
organizations
protecting the Amazon and its people
still poses immense challenges but
friends and colleagues of Dom Phillips
and Bruno Pereira have promised they
will keep their legacy alive
Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro